THE STORY CONTINUES.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
HAPPY DECEMBER 1ST, THE YEAR IS
ALMOST OVER, AND THANK HEAVEN IT
IS.
2020 HAS BEEN TOUGH ON EVERYONE.
AMERICANS ARE TIRED, FRUSTRATED,
DIVIDED AND ANGRY.
EIGHT MONTHS OF NONSTOP CRISIS
WILL DO THAT TO A COUNTRY.
EVERYONE COULD USE A BREAK.
UNFORTUNATELY IT DOESN’T LOOK
LIKE WE’RE GETTING A BREAK
ANYTIME SOON BECAUSE THERE’S A
NEW CRISIS ON THE HORIZON.
WE LEARNED ABOUT IT TODAY.
IT’S A BAD ONE WE ARE SAID TO
TELL YOU.
THIS IS A THREAT THAT IMPERILS
THE VERY EXISTENCE OF OUR
NATION.
IT’S NOT A MUTATED FORM OF THE
CORONAVIRUS NEWLY ARRIVED FROM
ASIA.
IT’S NOT AN EXOTIC NEW
PAINKILLER THAT WILL SILENTLY
KILL ANOTHER HUNDRED THOUSAND
AMERICANS IN UNFASHIONABLE
LITTLE TOWNS.
IT’S NOT EVEN OTHER EXODUS OF
MIDDLE CLASS JOBS TO CHINA.
IT’S WORSE THAN ANY OF THAT.
THE CRISIS IS YOU AND YOUR
SINFULNESS, YOUR INDELIBLE
PERSONAL BIGOTRY’S.
YOU ARE THE THREAT TO AMERICA.
THAT NEWS CAME TODAY FROM THE
MAYOR OF LOUISVILLE, KENTUCKY.
THAT MAYOR ’HIS NAME IS GREG
FISCHER.
AS A CIVIC LEADER IT’S FAIR TO
SAY THAT GREG FISCHER HAS NOT
BEEN A SUCCESS.
LOUISVILLE IS A MUCH WORSE PLACE
TO LIVE THAN IT WAS WHEN HE TOOK
OVER, SO AS A MAYOR, GREG
FISCHER HAS FAILED.
THAT’S UNDENIABLE.
SO HE’S FOUND A NEW CALLING NOW.
GREG FISCHER IS A PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERT.
THAT’S A JOB WITH FAR FEWER
REQUIREMENTS AND A MUCH MORE
LENIENT GRADING SCALE.
LISTEN TO DR. FISHER DESCRIBED
OUR NEW PANDEMIC.
>> OUR SYSTEMS ARE MORE THAN
BROKEN.
THEY MUST BE DISMANTLED AND
REPLACED.
THAT’S WHY AM ANNOUNCING TODAY
THAT I’M SIGNING AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER ACQUIRING RACISM A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS IN LOUISVILLE.
>> Tucker: SO RACISM IS A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS, SAYS GREG
FISCHER.
DR. FISHER PLANS TO ATTACK THIS
CRISIS WITH AN EXECUTIVE ORDER.
WILL MASKS HELP CONTAIN THE
SPREAD OF RACISM?
THEY CERTAINLY HAVEN’T BEFORE,
BUT WE WILL SEE.
OR MAYBE WE WON’T SEE.
THE BEAUTY OF FIGHTING RACISM,
LIKE FIGHTING SADNESS OR
ALIENATION OR EXISTENTIAL DREAD,
IS THAT THERE AREN’T VERY GOOD
MEASURES OF PROGRESS.
YOU CAN’T REALLY KNOW WHEN YOU
WON.
THE BATTLE GOES ON FOREVER.
YOU’RE ALWAYS JUSTIFIED IN
FIGHTING IT OF COURSE.
BY DEFINITION.
IN THE WAR AGAINST RACISM, YOU
ARE ALWAYS THE GOOD GUY.
ONE CAN CRITICIZE YOUR MOTIVES
OR EVEN YOUR [INDISCERNIBLE].
COMPARE THAT TO NORMAL POLITICS.
MUCH EASIER.
BY CONVENTIONAL POLITICAL
STANDARDS GREG FISCHER IS A
DISGRACE.
TWO OF LOUISVILLE’S BIG
EMPLOYERS LEFT HIS CITY.
HUGE NUMBERS OF PEOPLES ARE
STILL DYING FROM DRUG ODs.
THEY HAD RACE RIOTS OVER THE
SUMMER.
LOUISVILLE IS A MESS AND IT’S
FAIR TO SAY THAT GREG FISCHER IS
AT LEAST PARTLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
THAT MASS.
NOT SURPRISINGLY, GREG FISCHER
HAS NO INTEREST IN TALKING ABOUT
THAT.
WE WOULD MUCH RATHER TALK ABOUT
YOUR RACISM SO THAT’S WHAT HE’S
DOING.
IT’S AN OLD TRICK, OBVIOUSLY.
AL SHARPTON DOESN’T PAY HIS
TAXES AND THEN HE CALLS YOU A
BIGOT FOR ASKING HIM ABOUT IT.
BUT THE TACTIC SUDDENLY SEEMS
MORE POPULAR THAN EVER.
YOU SEE IT EVERYWHERE ALL OF A
SUDDEN.
AND THERE’S A REASON.
THE MORE OBVIOUS IT BECOMES THAT
THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE ARE STUPID
AND SELFISH, THE MORE TIME THEY
SPEND ATTACKING YOU AND THE
COUNTRY THEY’RE SUPPOSED TO BE
LEADING.
THEY DIVIDE US TO KEEP US FROM
NOTICING HOW AWFUL THEY ARE.
AND UNFORTUNATELY IT WORKS
PRETTY WELL AND THAT’S WHY THEY
DO IT.
LET’S SAY YOU WERE INCOMPETENT
AND DO DIDN’T WANT ANYONE TO
KNOW YOU WERE.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO?
WELCOME YOUR FIRST TASK WOULD BE
TO DESTROY THE MERITOCRACY.
THAT’S A SYSTEM THAT REWARDS
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY FOR THEIR
EFFORT AND THEIR TALENT AS
OPPOSED TO REWARDING THEM FOR
IRRELEVANT CRITERIA LIKE HOW
THEY LOOK.
A MERITOCRACY IS THE MAIN THREAT
TO INCOMPETENT PEOPLE.
IT KEEPS THE INCOMPETENT FROM
GETTING RICH AND POWERFUL, AND
SO THEY HATE IT ABOVE ALL.
THAT’S WHY THEY’RE TEARING IT
DOWN.
SO WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE IN
PRACTICE TO TEAR DOWN A
MERITOCRACY?
WELL, IT LOOKS A LOT LIKE
JOE BIDEN’S STAFFING OF
PRESIDENTIAL ADMINISTRATION.
A RECENT PIECE IN "POLITICO"
TELLS THE STORY.
ACCORDING TO POLITICO’S ACCOUNT,
THE CONGRESSIONAL BLACK CAUCUS
IS DEMANDING THAT BIDEN SELECTED
BLACK SECRETARY OF DEFENSE.
AT A SECRETARY OF DEFENSE WAS
GOOD AT DEFENDING AMERICA.
A SECRETARY OF DEFENSE WITH THE
CORRECT SKIN COLOR.
THE FEMINIST GROUPS ARE MAD
ABOUT THIS, SAYS POLITICO.
NOT MAD BECAUSE IT WOULD LEAD
THE COUNTRY -- LEAVE THE COUNTRY
VULNERABLE.
NO, BECAUSE THEY WANT A FEMALE
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE.
WHY DO THEY WANT A FEMALE
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE?
BECAUSE THEY ARE FEMALES.
THE SECRETARY OF DEFENSE SHOULD
LOOK LIKE THEM BECAUSE IT’S ALL
ABOUT THEM, NOT ABOUT THE
PENTAGON OR THE COUNTRY OR THE
MILITARY THREATS WE MIGHT FACE
IN THE FUTURE.
IT IS ABOUT IDENTITY, WHICH IS
TO SAY IT’S ABOUT NARCISSISM.
WHEN I SEE PEOPLE IN POWER, I
MUST SEE MYSELF.
THAT’S THE DEMAND.
AND NOT JUST THE DEMAND OF THE
PENTAGON.
HERE’S HOW BOX.COM SEVERED
STEVEN MNUCHIN.
"SEEN ON WALL STREET AND BY HER
SKEPTICS ON THE LEFT AT THE MOST
LIKELY TREASURY SECRETARY.
RAPHAEL BOSTIC, WHO WOULD BE THE
FIRST BLACK AND FIRST
OPENLY GAY’S TREASURY SECRETARY
IS ALSO SEE RECEIVING SOME
CONSIDERATION.
FOX WENT ON TO NOTE THAT SOME --
NO HISPANIC CANDIDATES
LEGITIMATELY IN THE MIX FOR THE
OTHER THREE TOP JOBS IN A BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
GOT THAT?
SPANISH, BLACK, GAY.
THOSE ARE CATEGORIES, THEY ARE
NOT PEOPLE, INDIVIDUALS.
THIS IS ABOUT IDENTITY, NOT
COUNTRY.
IT’S ABOUT VULCANIZATION, NOT
UNITY.
STRAIGHT WHITE MEN ARE THE
ENEMY, SAYS THE PARTY LED BY
ONE, AND SO IT GOES.
IT’S HARD TO IMAGINE ANYTHING
UGLIER THAN THIS.
IT’S HARD TO IMAGINE A MORE
ABRUPT CUL-DE-SAC.
IT’S DOESN’T GO ANYWHERE THAT
YOU WANT TO GO.
IT ENDS WITH DISCORD AND WORSE.
IT CONTINUES.
LISTEN TO "THE HUFFINGTON POST"
ACCOUNT OF THE STRUGGLE TO FILL
KAMALA HARRIS’ SENATE SEAT IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
"THREE MAIN CAMPS AND THEIR
SUBGROUPS ARE TRYING TO
INFLUENCE CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR NEWSOM.
THOSE ADVOCATING FOR BLACK
WOMAN, THOSE ADVOCATING FOR
LATINO AND THOSE ADVOCATING FOR
A MEMBER THE LGBT COMMUNITY."
IN OTHER WORDS, CERTAIN JOBS FOR
CERTAIN IDENTITIES.
CERTAIN SKIN COLORS HAVE
PREPRESCRIBED ROLES.
HOW IS THAT DIFFERENT FROM A
TRADITIONAL CASTE SYSTEM?
HOW IS THAT BETTER THAN THE
JIM CROW SOUTH?
THOSE ARE FAIR QUESTIONS, BUT NO
ONE EVER ASK THEM.
INSTEAD THE MEDIA JUST APPLAUD.
>> I DON’T REMEMBER A CABINET OR
A SENIOR APPOINTMENT THAT ARE
THIS DIVERSE.
>> I SUSPECT HE MAY WILL HAVE
ONE OF THE MOST DIVERSE CABINETS
IN THE HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY.
>> THE MOST DIVERSE STAFF THAT A
TRANSITION HAS EVER HAD.
>> HE PROMISED THE MOST DIVERSE
CABINET IN HISTORY.
>> THE MOST DIVERSE EVER
ASSEMBLED.
>> AND IT COULD BE THE MOST
DIVERSE EVER.
>> ASSEMBLING WHAT IS
ESSENTIALLY THE MOST DIVERSE
CABINET IN HISTORY.
>> PRESIDENT-ELECT BIDEN, VICE
PRESIDENT-ELECT KAMALA HARRIS
HAVE THE MOST DIVERSE AND
COMPETENT TEAM A PRESIDENT AND A
VICE PRESIDENT COULD POSSIBLY
HAVE.
>> Tucker: SO OBVIOUSLY THOSE
PEOPLE ARE UNIMPRESSIVE, DESPITE
THEIR CREDENTIALS, MINDLESSLY
REPEATING THE LATEST CORPORATE
SLOGAN.
BUT LISTEN TO WHAT THEY’RE
SAYING.
IT DIVERSITY, THAT IS THE
OVERRIDING GOAL OF EVERY
APPOINTMENT.
NOTICE WHAT THEY DON’T SAY.
NO ONE EVER EXPLAINS WHAT
EXACTLY DIVERSITY IS, NOT WITH
ANY PRECISION, OR JUSTIFIES THAT
DEFINITION.
NO ONE DARES TO FUND IT IS NOW
REQUIRED BY CORPORATE AMERICA.
THEIR DEFINITION OF DIVERSITY --
THE NASDAQ FOR EXAMPLE HAS
IMPOSED NEW RULES THAT REQUIRE
COMPANIES TO HAVE OR EXPLAIN WHY
THEY DO NOT HAVE AT LEAST TWO
DIVERSE DIRECTORS, INCLUDING ONE
WHO SELF IDENTIFIES AS FEMALE
AND ONE WHO SELF IDENTIFIES AS
EITHER AN UNDERREPRESENTED
MINORITY OR LGBTQ+.
NOT TO BE OUTDONE, THE BANK
SPEED 29 ANNOUNCED IT HAS
CREATED AN INDEX OF 350
"LGBTQ-INCLUSIVE COMPANIES" AND
THEY WILL OF COURSE BE REWARDED
ACCORDINGLY.
THINK THIS THROUGH FOR A MINUTE.
THERE’S A LOT OF MONEY AT STAKE
HERE WITH THESE DEFINITIONS AND
A LOT OF POWER THAT ATTACHES.
AT SOME POINT WE ARE GOING TO
MEET HIGHLY SPECIFIC WAYS TO
VERIFY THAT THE PEOPLE WERE
BENEFITING FROM THESE CATEGORIES
DESERVE TO.
THAT THEY ARE INDEED WOMEN,
WHATEVER THAT NOW MEANS, OR THAT
THEY ARE LEGITIMATELY LGBTQ+.
SO WELL THAT VERIFICATION LOOK
LIKE?
BLOOD TESTS?
HOME MONITORING?
WE WILL FIND OUT AT SOME POINT,
UNFORTUNATELY.
JENNY ALLEN DOESN’T SEEMED
WORRIED ABOUT THAT.
JOE BIDEN’S PICK FOR TREASURY
SECRETARY AND SHE IS ON BOARD
WITH ALL OF IT, MINDLESSLY,
SHE’S RICH ENOUGH TO BE BURIED
SHE’D EXPLAINED THAT
ILLUMINATING SOCIAL DISPARITIES,
HARD TO DEFINE, IS A CENTRAL
GOAL OF FEDERAL ECONOMIC POLICY
GOING FORWARD.
WATCH.
>> WE RISK MISSING THE
OBLIGATION TO ADDRESS DEEPER
STRUCTURAL PROBLEMS.
INEQUALITY, STAGNANT WAGES.
RACIAL DISPARITIES AND PAY, JOB
OPPORTUNITIES, HOUSING.
FOOD SECURITY AND SMALL BUSINESS
LENDING TO DENY BUILDING TO
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
GENDER DISPARITIES TO KEEP WOMEN
OUT OF THE WORKFORCE AND KEEP
OUR ECONOMY FROM RUNNING AT FULL
FORCE.
IT’S A CONVERGENCE OF TRAGEDIES.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
SO THE IDEA IS EVERYBODY PAYS
MONEY INTO THE FEDERAL TREASURY
THAT PUTS YOU IN JAIL IF YOU
DON’T, IT’S COMPULSORY.
THEY WILL USE FORCE IF THEY NEED
TO, BUT ONLY SOME PEOPLE BENEFIT
DEPENDING ON WHO JANET YELLEN
THINKS SHOULD BENEFIT, SO
THERE’S THAT, WE SHOULD DEBATE
THAT.
IT’S WORTH DEBATING, BUT STEP
BACK A FEW FEET.
WHAT’S MORE INTERESTING IS THAT
EVERYTHING YOU JUST HEARD IS THE
OPPOSITE OF THE ACTUAL TRUTH.
AND IF YOU’RE ACTUALLY IN FAVOR
OF DIVERSITY, REAL DIVERSITY,
YOU NOTICED THAT.
THE DIVERSITY MEASURES THEY ARE
PROPOSING WON’T MAKE ANYTHING
MORE DIVERSE, JUST THE OPPOSITE.
THESE PROPOSALS ARE MERELY A WAY
FOR THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE TO HIRE
MORE OF THEIR FRIENDS.
WHAT YOU’RE SEEING IS AN ATTEMPT
TO PRESERVE AND CODIFY THE CLASS
SYSTEM THAT IS ALREADY IN PLACE
AND UNFORTUNATELY THAT IS
GROWING MORE RIGID BY THE DAY.
IF YOU REALLY WANTED TO FLATTEN
AMERICA’S SOCIAL STRUCTURE, AND
WE WANT THAT, AND YOU SHOULD
TOO, BECAUSE AGAIN, THE SYSTEMS
ARE BAD AND WE NOW HAVE ONE.
IF YOU WANTED A FLATTER SOCIETY,
YOU WOULD DEMAND A RETURN TO
MERITOCRACY.
YOU WOULD WANT A SYSTEM WHERE
ANYONE, NO MATTER WHERE THEY
WERE BORN OR WHAT THEY LOOK LIKE
OR WHO THEY SLEPT WITH COULD
SUCCEED.
THAT’S WHAT WE USED TO HAVE,
IT’S WHY WE WERE PROUD OF
AMERICA, BUT IT’S THE OPPOSITE
OF WHAT THE LEFT IS NOW
DEMANDING.
SO IF YOU REALLY WANTED TO MAKE
COMPANIES MORE DIVERSE -- AND
AGAIN, WE ARE FOR THAT -- YOU
WOULD ACTUALLY TRY TO DIVERSIFY
THEM.
THAT MEANS YOU WOULD HIRE PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT IN ANY SENSE LIKE
YOU.
PEOPLE WITH DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS, ACTUALLY DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS.
YOU WOULD HIRE MORE PEOPLE WITH
TECHNICAL DEGREES FOR EXAMPLE IF
YOU ARE WHO STUDIED OR
COMMUNICATIONS.
YOU WOULD FIND PEOPLE WHO LIVED
IN RURAL ZIP CODES, DEEP IN
RURAL ZIP CODES.
YOU SEEK OUT EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
DEEPLY INVOLVED IN THEIR
CHURCHES OR OWN GUNS WHO HAD
CLOSE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO DIED OF
OPIOID ODs.
AND MORE THAN ANYTHING, ON DAY
ONE, YOU WOULD PUT A CAP ON THE
NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES WHO WENT TO
ELITE COLLEGES.
THAT’S JUST START WITH THE TOP
100 ON THE U.S. NEWS ANNUAL
LIST.
YOU WOULD OUTRIGHT BAN HARVARD,
YALE, PRINCETON AND STANFORD
GRADUATES COMPLETELY.
THEY’VE GOT ENOUGH
REPRESENTATION TO LAST THE NEXT
HALF-CENTURY.
YOU’D MAKE ANY PREVIOUS
EMPLOYMENT AT ANY McKINSEY AND
COMPANY OR ANY OTHER ABSURD
CONSULTING FIRM INSTANTLY
DISQUALIFIED.
YOU WOULD LOOK BEYOND RACE AND
SEX TO THE CULTURAL MARKERS THAT
ACTUALLY MATTER AND ACTUALLY
DETERMINE LATER SUCCESS IN A
CLASS SYSTEM.
YOU WOULD SUBTRACT ONE FROM AN
APPLICANT WHO HAD EVER SPENT THE
NIGHT ON NANTUCKET OR MARTHA’S
VINEYARD OR SAINT BART’S AND HE
WOULD ADD POINTS TO APPLICANTS
WHO HAVE VACATIONED IN BRANSON
OR LAKE MEAD OR THE FLORIDA
PANHANDLE.
YOU WOULD START AN AGGRESSIVE
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION PROGRAM FOR
FAT PEOPLE, FOR DEER HUNTERS,
FOR ANYONE WHO DRIVES AN
AMERICAN CAR OR EATS DINNER
WHILE WEARING A HAT.
ARE THOSE PEOPLE REPRESENTED ON
CORPORATE BOARDS?
I DON’T THINK SO.
FIND A FAT PERSON CORPORATE
AMERICA.
THERE’S NOT ONE.
WHY IS THAT?
YOU KNOW WHY.
OUR LEADERS ARE DOING THE
OPPOSITE OF ANY OF THAT.
WHAT YOU’RE SEEING IS THE RULING
CLASS FOLLOWING UP -- PULLING UP
THE LADDER, AS THEY ALWAYS DO.
HOW MAY PEOPLE LECTURING ABOUT
DIVERSITY COME FROM EXACTLY THE
SAME ELITE BACKGROUND?
WELL, PRETTY MUCH ALL OF THEM,
SO WHAT THEY’RE ADVOCATING FOR
HIS PEOPLE JUST LIKE THEMSELVES.
WE CAN GIVE YOU A THOUSAND
EXAMPLES.
TAKE MARCUS MAYBURY.
HE RUNS GLOBAL DIGITAL
PROGRAMMING AT CNN, BEEN AROUND
JOURNALISM FOREVER.
HE’S NOW ONE OF CNN’S MOST
ENERGETIC DIVERSITY ENFORCERS.
HE NEVER ENDS THE SENTENCE
WITHOUT USING THE WORD DIVERSE.
THAT’S HIS JOB.
AND HERE’S THE INTERESTING PART.
HE HIMSELF WAS A HIGH SCHOOL AT
[INDISCERNIBLE] ACADEMY.
HE GOT TO GO TO GREECE FROM
STANFORD AND THEN HE PENT
DECADES AT "NEWSWEEK,"
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," AND
TWITTER, SO NATURALLY POINTS TO
BE HIGHLY CONCERNED ABOUT
INCLUSION.
LISTEN TO AND FROM JUST A FEW
YEARS AGO LECTURING HIS
THEN-EMPLOYER ABOUT IT.
>> THERE WAS A LOT OF WORK TO DO
AT TWITTER AND THROUGHOUT TAP
AND ONE OF THE REASONS I CAME TO
TWITTER IS I THINK IT’S SO
IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE AT THE
TABLE.
IT WAS TRUE OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" TOO BUT WE
HAVE TO MAKE MORE OF US.
WE HAVE TO CREATE MORE OF US AND
THAT’S AFRICAN-AMERICAN BUT ALSO
LATINO AND HISPANIC SORE VERY
MUCH ALSO UNDERREPRESENTED IN
TECHNOLOGY AND AT TWITTER AND
TWITTER -- I’M CONVINCED OUR
CURRENT LEADERSHIP IS COMMITTED,
BUT THERE’S A LOT OF WORK TO DO.
>> Tucker: DOES A LOT OF WORK
TO DO TO MAKE SURE THAT MORE OF
US ARE AT THE TABLE, PEOPLE WHO
WENT TO LAWRENCEVILLE AND GOT A
MASTERS DEGREE AT STANFORD!
THEY ARE NOT ENOUGH!
WE ARE UNDERREPRESENTED!
NOW ON THE BOARD OF ONE OF THE
MOST EXPENSIVE BOARDING SCHOOLS
IN THE WORLD, HE’S FIGHTING A
MAN!
OF COURSE HE IS!
IT’S WORKING FOR HIM!
IT’S WORKING FOR ALL HIS
FRIENDS!
IT’S JUST NOT WORKING FOR YOU